apa
durch meine lieben freund und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einer neuen mod
vorstellung in meinen kräften treffer
der partie
roger ist eigentlich pop die mutter ist
eigentlich motto la paz muss er wegen
der hotspot
das ist eine mod die pure freude diese
bot finden wir im inventar ihn wieder
einen neuen seite hier da sehen wir
diese video enorm ich will auch noch
ganz ernst
es geht nämlich einfach grundsätzlich
darum in dieser modifikation dass es
mehr posten gibt also blumentopf arten
ihr kennt ja wahrscheinlich nur wenn ich
hier mal in der suche blumentopf da
haben wir den eingebe haben wir ja nur
diesen kleinen blumentopf hallo co haben
wir nur diesen kleinen blumentopf 4 wo
wir dann sogar drei stellen können wie
weiß nicht an da sogar gras rhein neckar
nicht rein aber ich kann so was ihn
setzen reinstellen oder sowas wegen
teilen kaktus oder eine blume oder als
so kleine sachen halt so relativ wenig
auswahlmöglichkeiten allerdings macht
diese module flowerbox mode mode mode
modul mod model j j motiv stellt mehrere
neue möglichkeiten des webs
wahrscheinlich schon auf dem meer
gesehen und sieht es auch hier gerade
schon
wir haben hier viele neue möglichkeiten
ich zeige euch erst mal ganz kurz mit
inventar was du alles unter anderem ist
wir haben nämlich hier die verschiedenen
frauen ports und verschiedenen farben
dann haben wir hier post also das sind
so nicht trotz sondern post also spd der
in tutorials programm
merkel teile die wir so quasi den boden
stellen kannst wie die auf jeder kuh
farben quasi sind dann irgendwelchen
ecken oder irgendwie sowas solche teile
sind das einfach ein risiko das sind
jetzt nicht solche sachen wie ganz
normale zeuner sie seht ich kann hier so
einfach ganz normal easy rüberspringen
also ich kann damit jetzt nicht
irgendwas abgrenzen oder so aber ich
kann da nicht zwischen herlaufen und ich
kann dir auch noch ein bisschen höher
bauen und zwar jetzt seht ihr schon die
verbinden sich dann hier oben und dann
haben wir so eine art zaun also dann
kann ich deutlich rüber springen hier
kann ich mich dann halt wieder da drauf
stellen seht ihr ja das sind dann so
half blog mäßig mehr oder weniger moment
ich stehe auf dem blog okay das ist
nicht nicht half blogs jetzt ein
bisschen mehr als auf blogger sicher
geht da was meine die verbinden sich
dann halt hier und so weiter und so fort
da kann man halt so ein bisschen was
abgrenzte jeder schon verbinden sich
hier mit blöcken und so weiter das heißt
wenn ich hier quasi noch ein rein
stellen würde wäre das ganze dann so in
etwa kann man ein paar sachen mit bauen
also das sind halt diese jungle world
post die ich euch gerade gezeigt habe
die crafted man sich ganz einfach so in
dem man entweder eine holz axt nimmt und
mit einem eichenholz ins inventar packt
und dann bekommt man vier auch posts
oder wir machen das ganz einfach so
eichenholz übereinander finde ich sogar
eigentlich noch besser obwohl ja das ist
glaube ich sogar noch besser vom form
von crafting dingsda verbraucht man mal
nicht sogar weniger ressourcen das sind
halt mehr so deko sachen die aber auch
so ein bisschen funktionalität
mitbringen also eine schönere art um
ihnen was abzugrenzen genau das gleiche
gibt es auch schon wie ihr hier ist hier
sind beispielsweise post fences da ist
es so dass will diese grün die ganze
zeit da ist es so die betrachtet man
sich so da macht man noch zwei fäden
dazu nimmt schon diese post dann hat man
diese teile hat die hier quasi so das
sind dann halt einfach so fans das ist
dann quasi das was ihr da gerade gesehen
habt nur in der fans also wenn ich dir
jetzt beispielsweise hier zusammen
ständeräte schon da werden dann nach
derzeit so komische fäden zwischendrin
als wenn die so verbunden wären das ist
quasi einfach nur der unterschied bei
den hier vorne ist es ja nur so wenn ich
die nebeneinander stelle stehen die
wirklich einfach nebeneinander aber die
kann ich drüber springen und über die
hier wenn ich da versuche darüber zu
springen geht es nicht das sind halt
einfach die fans ist deswegen steht doch
dahinter das design von denen kann
besser sein aber das ist der große
unterschied zwischen den sachen also man
müsste sich um diese fans hier zu
bekommen in verschiedenen holzarten sich
erstmal die machen und die dann zusammen
mit
strings und rafting table tun und dann
sollte das auch schon laufen und dann
kommen wir jetzt mal zu den anderen
sachen zu die flowerbox nämlich dass sie
es ist ein ganz normaler fraport also
nicht ganz normaler sondern ein ganz
normaler fraport in dieser modifikation
den crafted man sich ganz einfach indem
ich ganz normalen ton hier so zusammen
betonen wie man tun bekommen sollte
jeder wissen
sieben ton so antwortete zusammen und
dann bekommt man drei roller portugal
demand in welcher wir nicht an ganz easy
hier einfach hinsetzen ihr werdet schon
ich packte ihr ex amazon bisschen
auseinander
seht ihr auch gleich warum weil wenn ich
die zusammenpackte seht ihr schon okay
bei diesem prozess ist es so wenn ich
die hierhin setzte dann verbinden die
sich aber wahrscheinlich ist das einfach
bei diesem roller plot ist es gar nicht
so da hier können sich gar nicht so
richtig verbinden
aber die würde ich auch nicht nehmen ich
finde diesen einfach nur grottig scheiße
aus und zwar kann man sich aus denen die
kann man nicht in den ofen tun da oben
bestimmen der so eine scheiße man
einfach im ofen tun und mit einer kohle
ganz normal rein da bekommt man einen
leitpflock und ich empfehle euch aber
den ton direkt zu brennen dann so zu
machen damit kommt man nämlich drei
russen auch besser dafür braucht man
nämlich weniger ressourcen wenn man auf
quantität geht hat man drei laut
schlauer potts kann ich dann so
hinsetzen und dann kann ich die auch
zusammen verbinden das kann ich dann so
wie hier machen beispielsweise oder wie
hier
wenn ich allerdings eine andere farbe
damit zu packen dann geht das ganze
nicht und es geht auch nicht wenn ihr
sehen wenn ich die übereinander packe
kann ich jetzt nicht noch ein großes
ding da reinpacken oder so sondern die
würden sich dann halt nur hier unten
drunter dann irgendwie verbinden wenn
ich da auch meinen draufsetzen sowie ein
bisschen komisch denke habt ihr auch
standen ich gebe euch immer um mit
seiner rasselbande von hunden oder
irgendwie so das tut mir sehr leid wenn
ich immer so sage habt ihr das
verstanden die sonne lehrerin
aber ich bin doch eigentlich tierärzte
sind dann haben wir hier natürlich auch
wie ihr schon seht die teile auch noch
in verschiedenen farben wenn ich mal
hier schon die gibt es nicht nur in dem
normalen gebranntem ton und auch nicht
in den normalen packen und original
dings und auch nicht in jeder sondern
auch in anderen farben dazu ganz easy
crafting rezept einfach einen laut
fraport zusammen mit beispielsweise
gelben farbstoff grün rot blau pink
magenta et cetera dann bekommt man die
jeweilige farbe raus und das ganze geht
auch so also können auch direkt
gefärbten ton nehmen und daraus bekommen
wir dann drei raus und hier bekommen wir
nur einen rauslassen wie immer die
kostengünstigere variante sage ich mal
ist es nicht
nächstes nicht guck mal hier bräuchte
ich für jeden einen gelben farbstoff und
da nur für ihr kann ich mir nämlich
einfach einen leitpfosten und einen
gelben farbstoff das heißt ich
verbraucher einen gelben farbstoff und
ein yellow flashmob ort zu bekommen hier
verbrauche ich sieben farbstoffe um 3 zu
bekommen das ist dann natürlich nicht so
gut ich hab den schnitt kombiniert oder
und hier sehen wir das dann auch schon
wieder und das ganze hat anordnen kann
habe ich euch ja gerade schon gezeigt da
kann ich dann jetzt einfach mal so
sachen einpacken wie beispielsweise ich
nehme mal jetzt einfach mal sand nehme
ich mir da nehme ich mit kies und ganz
normal erde dann kann ich ja
beispielsweise mal erde reinpacken hier
kies hier sand und ihr seht auch unter
anderem wenn ich beispielsweise hier
sind rheinpark und hier sind und hier
sind verbindet sich das ganze das heißt
ich kann wenn ich mal hier so eine
kleine fläche mal eben kreieren da
könnte ich beispielsweise sagen ich mach
dich hier voll mit sand und dann mache
ich hier vorne noch den eine kleine ecke
mit dem mit dem dem mit dem erde und
dann könig als rein theoretisch mir mal
einfach so ein kaktus nehme den ihr
draufsetzen und dann habe ich jedenfalls
mein eigenes bier um gemacht das kann
man so groß machen will das erweitert
sich dann halt immer weiter diese teile
oder kann ich hier rein theoretisch dann
noch mal so ein bisschen hiervon dahin
packen und dann hier noch mal so ein
bisschen sand und so dass hier verbindet
sich nicht weil es einfach zwei
unterschiedliche flops sind aber ich
denke ihr habt verstanden hier wieder
tierärztin lehrerin luca am starter und
damit kann ich mir dann quasi so kleine
eigene biome schaffen allerdings kann
ich jetzt nicht so sachen reinpacken wie
beispielsweise holz oder so das wird
dann einfach oben drauf gehen oder hier
drüber sondern da kann wirklich nur
zusammen rein so sand kies erde so was
in die richtung hat es gibt auch noch
eine andere möglichkeit an die flowerbox
ranzukommen das ist über dieses teil und
zwar ist das der porsche retail und
dafür braucht man auch noch diese
gewissen teile die einfach clay patterns
times sind die packt man hier ein
hier im blog blog dann bekommt man
schneller die teile raus aber das ist
jetzt auch egal erstmal eigentlich für
das ist die grobe vorstellung dass da
wollte ich auch gar nicht so sehr darauf
eingehen das ist auf der website noch
mal erklärt die ich euch in die
beschreibung gepackt habe kommen wir zur
letzte sache die ich euch noch zeigen
wollte hier die teilhabe ich euch an
schon gezeigt und zwar kann man mit
roten farbstoff kaktus grün und zwei
glasflaschen sich ein seil testkit
machen und das ist jetzt einfach ein
test geht damit kann ich jetzt das ist
jetzt hier noch leer da es steht noch
nichts es gibt allerdings auch welche
die das zeige ich euch jetzt erstmal
zwar kann ich mir jetzt einfach
rechtsklick auf den boden machen habt
ihr gesehen
die teile hier voll und da steht jetzt
temperature 0,7 rain von 0,8 und daran
kann ich jetzt bestimmen beziehungsweise
sehen wie sehr mein biom quasi so mehr
oder weniger wie warm es ist wie oft
regen kommt und so weiter und so fort
also damit ist es quasi möglich zu sehen
ob ich rein theoretisch wenn ich in der
wüste wohnen wohnen würde wie da meine
temperaturbedingungen wehren und dann
kann ich das ganze ding hier nehmen und
auf einen witz ich muss hier mal eben
kurz landen wo folgende tatsache ich bin
jetzt hier in einem anderen biom und wir
haben jetzt hier beispielsweise dieses
eine temperature 07 rain von 0,8 ich geh
jetzt hier beispielsweise nehme ich mir
mal was ist auch noch 07 08 und jetzt
könnte ich mir rein theoretisch einfach
wenn ich in der wüste wohnen würde
magazine frost biom hinsetzen weil wenn
ich hier mit rechts drauf machen kommen
so grüne partikelchen und dieser blog
hat jetzt also die temperaturen die rain
von eigenschaften hoffe dass verstanden
es ist halt quasi so ich nehme mir mit
diesem ding mache ich rechtsklick und
nehme mir die eigenschaften dieses bio
ich gerade bin und packe sie auf diesem
blog hier mehr oder weniger drauf also
da kommt jetzt keine partikelchen mehr
weil ich das ja gerade schon gemacht
habe aber damit kann man quasi diese
flowerbox wirklich jetzt internet modul
a flower potts also ich kann die
wirklich auch modellieren ich kann die
die wie gesagt hat ich kann die
temperatur verändert in rain voll die
farbe was da drin ist die größe alles
mögliche kann ich damit machen finde ich
sehr sehr gerne mit der mode kann man
auf jeden fall einiges machen ist so
eine wieder sonne recht unnötige
modifikation aber das sind die mods die
wiso hakt es jetzt so muss die ich mag
einfach so simple modifikation ist was
so hektisch viele zugefügt werde man
sich erst mal zehn jahre lang einlesen
muss bevor mein spiel sich jetzt gleich
noch auf hängt weil das irgendwie grad
schon ganze ein bisschen doof ampeln ist
würde ich sagen ich hoffe euch hat das
video gefallen wenn ihr eine geile mod
kennt schreibt mir die kommentare dann
werde ich die eventuell demnächst mal
vorstellen dann würde ich mich freuen